here's noted black lesbian Karin
Jean-Pierre talking about Nordstrom
except she thinks it's Nordstroms
what what we see Russia's doing and
we've been very clear about this is that
they're using energy they're weaponizing
energy and it's choosing to to one of
the things that has been out there that
shut down the pipeline of Nordstrom one
Nordstrom's going down people Nordstrom
Rack you're not going to get those
half-price jackets okay where you think
you're going to get all your uh your
nice shirts and they often have wallets
there some perfume a little bit cheaper
that sort of thing you're not going to
get it because Russia and the energy or
something
kind of put together a nice little
package for us on this Nordstrom
situation one of the things that has
been out there to shut down the pipeline
of Nordstrom one
[Music]
that's some fine work there Connor
you're getting extra guacamole today
okay so now we're in this situation
where as you guys know since well really
since Joe Biden took office but really
escalated in the last like six months
you know gas prices have gone crazy
they've now dropped a tiny bit a tiny
bit which has the whole Administration
saying see gas prices are going down and
it's always like yes they're going down
a tiny bit because thanks to your
incompetence and everything you've done
to the economy they went up so high and
now they're going down a tiny bit you
want credit for that
um but Biden knows that there's about to
be another spike in gas prices right
this we are in an interconnected world
if a massive pipeline blows up that's
sending energy to Germany then it's
going to affect prices here it's just
how it is right and we seem to be
playing into every one of Putin's moves
so he wants to make sure that the blame
doesn't go on him for this Nordstrom
I did it for this Nordstrom situation so
he wants to blow flame oil and gas
Executives because of the hurricane you
know they're going to price gouge you I
also want to say again to the oil and
gas Executives do not do not do not use
this storm as an excuse to raise
gasoline prices or gouge the American
public the price of oil is dropped in
recent weeks the price of gas should be
going down as rapidly as not
my experts inform me the production of
only about 160 000 barrels a day has
been impacted by this storm that's less
than two percent of our country's daily
production it's small and temporary
impact on oil production provides no
excuse no excuse for price increases at
the pump period if a gas station
companies try to use this storm to raise
prices I'm going to ask I'm going to ask
officials to look into whether or not
price gouging is going on it's just so
incredible because he is the price
gouger in Chief he is the one that has
caused inflation with crazy spending and
the inflation reduction act and all of
these things and all of our bad policies
instead of drilling here and now he
knows because of this war that gas
prices are rising because of whoever
blew up the Nordstrom pipeline gas
prices are going to rise and who's he
threatening he's threatening the gas
companies and he's threatening the mom
and pop shops that are your local gas
station that's who he's threading he is
the gouger in Chief